- Hi everybody. Oh, a live audience.
- Have y'all met? Have you met Constance?
- We have met, you've
been over on our show
and of course on red carpets
and it's so good to see you again.
- Yeah, it's good to see you too.
- And I'm excited about your memoir.
- Thank you.
- Okay so Kit, you say
there was one week that-
of your life that really challenged you.
What was that like, 'cause-
- Well, any parent-
every week has been challenging.
But no, I was listening to you backstage
and of course you and I
talked last time we were on
everything that you've been through.
I think everybody goes
through so much stuff.
You never know what's going on
in someone else's life and...
- [Kelly] Amen.
- Your producers were asking me that.
I thought about it.
I had this one week where
my house had burned down.
I lost everything I own
when I was eight months
pregnant with my third child.
Everything, pictures, everything.
- [Constance] Oh my God.
- I was removed from my job.
They decided to go in a
different direction at ESPN.
So I was sort of let go,
which never feels good
but it was the right move for ESPN.
My parents got divorced
after 40 years of marriage
and my cousin took his own life.
It was like it a little more
than a week, a couple of weeks.
But I had that moment where
I was like, okay this is...
- How much can one handle.
- One handle. But you never
know what someone's going
through in their life.
And I was born on third
base having the mom
and dad and brother that I have that
with that support and love
and I am rose colored glasses.
Like for example...
- You are so positive.
- I am. Yeah. I think I'm wired this way.
Yeah. And then the house burned down.
Again that was 15 years ago.
And then last year a man high on drugs
broke into our home while we were home.
My teenage daughters up- were gone.
He went up the stairs into
their rooms, took everything.
My son was playing video games.
My husband and I were-
had the bedroom door closed
so the cat wouldn't get in
and he robbed us blind,
drove off in our car
including stole my
Haagen-Dazs ice cream bars.
He had a sweet tooth.
- [Kelly] What?
- Those are expensive;
there's only three in a pack.
You know the ones I'm talking about.
Do you know what I mean?
And, but the best part
about the rose color
is my daughter Hayes said to me
Oh my gosh, mom, we're so cursed.
This is my middle daughter.
She's like, the house burned
down and now this guy broke in.
And I said, no, we are blessed.
We were not home during the fire
and we never saw the man that broke in.
We found... They found
him living out of our car
but we never saw him.
So it was like the best one-
- [Kelly] How big is that house?
- Not big. My dad was visiting.
My 88 year old dad slept
through the whole thing.
He's like, Everybody good?
And he went back to bed.
I was like
- This is like a show!
- I know. Who does this happen to?
- Like I wouldn't believe this script.
- No. And they found him
from the DNA from one
of the Haagen-Dazs bars that he dropped.
- [Constance] No. No, that's too perfect.
- But I mean, I just
think life you put on-
I just tend to sort of
say, okay, we are blessed.
Like it could have been so much worse.
- [Constance] Nobody was hurt?
= Nobody was hurt. And we didn't-
- Also, nobody looks at that
as a positive situation Kit.
No one.
I'm like really positive
and I don't know that I-
- [Kit] It was a tough one
- But it's a blessing.
- Yes, I know.
I'm kind of annoying that way.
So I was thinking my
memoir would have to be
like rose colored glasses or something.
Yeah. Even this, you know,
I got this job at age 40.
Yeah. I'm now 52 and I feel
like having to hit my stride.
So I was was like, that's
another positive thing.
- No, that is good.
Your book would be very
interesting as well.
Well Kit, we've gotta
talk about your shows. So-
I said plural shows.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- What's new on Access this season?
- My name is in the title, ladies.
(woman makes horn noise)
There it is. You know what that means?
13 years I've been there
and now I can show up
without my badge, right?
And I told them I love it so much
I'm gonna show up regardless,
but that just secures me maybe
for a little bit longer.
Having a ball.
- But that's amazing.
My face is literally
on this building and I
still have to show my badge
(women laugh)
- But it looks different coming in, Kit
- So, they're probably
like, "No you're not."